good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-2006 object
class Keter special containment
procedures scp-2006 is to be contained
at site 118 in an airtight container
cell scp-2006 must be constantly
monitored for changes in form which are
to be noted immediately
all personnel coming into contact with
scp-2006 are required to enroll in an
acting course with a focus on expressing
fear and surprise every month scp-2006
is to be shown at least one new
extremely low quality horror or science
fiction movie containing horror elements
all interaction with scp-2006 must
confirm that scp-2006 continues to
believe that said works demonstrate a
superb grasp of horror description
scp-2006 is an anomalous spherical
entity roughly 50 centimetres in
diameter when in its default state
scp-2006 is stated goal is to cause
feelings of fear and or horror in as
many humans as possible to accomplish
this purpose scp-2006 possesses the
ability to change its shape mass volume
density chemical structure and voice to
any form that it desires currently there
is no way to damage scp-2006 the extent
of its shape-shifting abilities is
unknown and is currently thought to be
unlimited
currently scp-2006 has demonstrated a
fondness for taking forms of various
entities and villains from the various
horror and science fiction movies that
it is witnessed the most common form
that scp-2006 is taken is that of the
rumen from the 1953 movie robot monster
scp-2006 is capable of speaking even
when it possesses the form of an entity
that is normally unable to speak
scp-2006 will generally attempt to
startle and/or scare any individual it
comes into contact with but after doing
so will become affable and friendly the
reason behind this is currently unknown
although a CP 2006 has repeatedly stated
its goal of causing as much fear as
possible as CP 2006 is a poor judge of
concepts that cause fear in humans and
constantly searches for new methods in
which to accomplish its goal this poor
recognition extends to recognition of
emotions in humans as scp-2006 is
incapable of distinguishing between
subtle differences in emotion that would
be obvious to a human this is interview
long scp-2006 playing log
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so something that you wanted to talk
about doc yeah yes I was wondering what
exactly do you feel the need to cause
fear in others I don't understand the
question
that is why do you scare people
oh that's an easy one people because
it's fun you know that's why I do just
like you to talk to yourself
I do stuff above it man you are
I'll take my leave then I'll have some
really scary stuff next time addendum
the current site director for site 118
has issued the following memorandum
regarding scp-2006
attention all personnel I've been
getting reports of some of the lakhs
behavior regarding a CP 2006 many
personnel have been heard laughing at
scp-2006 during surveillance when it
watches a new movie or when it attempts
to scare individuals some personnel have
been heard questioning why scp-2006 is
classified as a Keter entity I am here
to remind you that a Keter entity is a
Keter entity regardless of how innocuous
it may seem no scp-2006 is not a
rampaging demigod nor is it a
regenerating super lizard however it
possesses the same level of danger as
any other Keter that the foundation has
contained you think of scp-2006 is
purpose it wishes to scare people
imagine what would happen if scp-2006
broke containment and found out what
really scared people imagine if it saw
the horror and fear of war or the
concepts of paranoia or phobias common
to each and every human being
imagine if it found the true horror of a
nuclear holocaust or an XK class
scenario now couple that with an entity
that possesses shape-shifting abilities
with no known limits and you will
understand why it's classified as Keter
all personnel mentioned above have been
suitably disciplined I do not want to
hear about this again this is dr.
Randall Owings site 118 director signing
out
yeah okay and I think that about does it
for today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you're all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to permit the reclusive extrovert James
Saba Darius Tom arbiter Sewell Tyler
Sean
Justin day o philia gray Durham Curie
kuma and jayvo Jack Jonathan Augusto and
dr. Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you